we have data now from the nih there was
that 2018 kevin hall study that found
that people
on ultra-processed diets
when
when invited to consume ultra-processed
foods add libitum meaning to satiety
all the food that they wanted they ended
up eating a 500 calorie per day
surplus
and if you stretch that out over the
course of the week 500 calories a day
that's a pound of fat gain every week
when they took those same people and
they gave them
minimally processed foods to consume
they ended up coming in at a calorie
deficit by about 300 calories so that's
an 800 calorie swing right there
determined purely by what you're eating
not by how much you're eating so what
it's what seems to be the case is that
what you eat determines at least to some
degree to a significant degree how much
you're eating
[Music]
hello and welcome to episode 106 of the
michaela peterson podcast in this
episode i'm joined by
max lugavir
i was very happy to have him for the
second time on my podcast he was my
guest
on the second episode of this podcast
when i screwed up the video and it was
only audio the good old days
max is a health and science journalist
and a new york times best-selling author
he returned to discuss more lifestyle
options to promote and prevent degrading
brain health you guys do not want that
this episode will be interesting for
anyone who wants to learn about brain
health everybody should
eating healthy food caffeine and more
and want someone who's more middle of
the road healthy diet he makes sense to
the gluten eaters even they can
understand this guy
if you're not into going so restrictive
on your diet that you only survive off
of cows i get it i feel that and that's
where max comes in handy everyone who
eats the standard american diet should
read his books and listen to this guy
don't forget to subscribe if you like
this episode this episode is brought to
you by superspeciosa superspeciosa is a
kratom company kratom is a
herb related to the coffee plant the
leaves or extracts from the leaves like
in this bag
have been used as a stimulant and a
sedative it works on opiate receptors in
the brain so it's been used to treat
chronic pain digestive ailments and aid
in withdrawal from opiate dependency
i always advocate for dietary changes to
enhance mood before anything else diet
exercise saunas avoiding inflammatory
foods and poison but if you're still
having trouble and you've already tried
super specious cbd tincture they've got
high quality cbd products as well and
you felt like it isn't quite what you're
looking for or even if you like their
cbd but you want to try something else
just for fun maybe or for help whatever
kratom might be for you kratom is great
for energy support some people will use
it as a substitute for coffee or as a
pre-workout to get amped up
some people use it to manage stress to
help them relax
superspeciosa has different strains some
help you relax some give you energy the
most important part
of this company
is super specious kratom is reliable
third-party lab tested and approved
under the american kratom's
association's quality standards program
only natural kratom no other ingredients
remember this works on opiate receptors
so it can cause dependence if you overdo
it so do your research google everything
you take be super paranoid know your
[ __ ] i do i've been someone who's come
off of opiates multiple times from
surgeries and i wish i'd known about
something like kratom during those
lovely periods of time if you want to
try some
you can get 20 off if you go to
getsuperleaf.com
mp and enter code mp for 20 off that's
get
superleaf.com
mp promo code mp for twenty percent off
enjoy the rest of this episode
[Music]
max luber here welcome to my podcast
again it's so good to be back for a
second time what an incredible honor
it's good to see you
thank you it's good to see you too in
case anyone hasn't seen the first
episode the first episode did not have
video because i didn't know how to do a
podcast
and so it was only audio because the
video didn't work so this time it has
video but if they haven't seen the first
one can you give a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
yeah absolutely and also thank you for
having me on as one of the first
episodes i was one of the premier
episodes of your podcast so whatever
what an incredible
uh privilege that was um
so my name is max lugovir i'm a health
and science journalist i started as a
generalist my career began as a
producer and journalist for a tv network
in the united states that i did for six
years but i've always had a penchant for
health and nutrition and health science
uh in college i spent the first three
years on a pre-med track but
i pivoted when i realized that i
loved storytelling and creativity and
that
um
i had more of an entrepreneurial brain i
think i've always had
uh
subclinical add in the sense that it was
always very hard for me to focus on
things that i wasn't very passionate
about and so for that reason my grades
academically i was just never
you know an amazing student the kind of
student that would be competitive had i
gone the med school route
and ultimately i think i made the best
decision for me and my own personal
happiness so i went into
this field as a as a journalist and um
i did that for six years and then
when i left that job where i got to work
with some of the best of the best in the
field
it was then in my personal life that my
mother got sick
and she developed what would ultimately
be diagnosed as a rare form of dementia
a form of dementia called lewy body
dementia which is akin to having
parkinson's disease and alzheimer's
disease at the same time
and as i mentioned i'd always been
passionate about health and nutrition so
i when this happened in my personal life
i decided to step in and go with my mom
to all the doctors appointments and
ultimately
we ended up in cleveland ohio where she
was prescribed drugs for both
alzheimer's disease and parkinson's
disease for the first time
and
what i experienced in every doctor's
office from the local
clinic
just across the street from my mom's
house in new york to
the cleveland clinic which is one of the
most storied
um academic medical institutions that
the united states has
i experienced what i've come to call
diagnose and adios you know very little
is in the way of diet and lifestyle is
talked about a physician basically runs
a battery of esoteric tests
where they write down a few
prescriptions on the pad
none of which being any kind of dietary
or lifestyle intervention and they send
you on your way
and that
stoked a curiosity in me
to use the tools that i had acquired the
skills that i'd acquired as a as an
investigator to try to look into the
medical literature to see if there was
anything that could be done
from a more holistic standpoint to help
my mom
and
in tandem with that what could be done
to prevent
cognitive decline from being something
that i ever have to contend with because
i'm somebody who values my my my brain
my creative output my intellectual
output and so
i just began to dive in and i i came at
it from a place of again curiosity i
knew nothing at the time although i had
a foundational um passion for nutrition
and you know as a as a journalist you're
trained not as rigorously as a scientist
but you know how to identify what is a
credible source versus what is not a
credible source and
um i've been sort of plugged into
fitness circles and and that and the
like for many many years at that point
so
i just began to look and look further
and
i read as much as i could find on pubmed
i started you know i read every book
that i could find i started watching ted
talks like i left no stone unturned and
then ultimately i decided
that i was able i i realized that i was
able to use my
media credentials my status as a
quasi-public figure
to reach out to scientists and
researchers and this is before
podcasting really was a thing so i
didn't have a podcast at this point i
was just somebody who had a blue check
mark on on twitter and i began reaching
out to people who were really sort of
ushering in that i would see as the you
know
first and last authors in these in these
in the primary literature that i was
reading that were really ushering in
this notion of dementia as a potentially
preventable condition
and i i
wanted to interview them so i began to
interview them for a few projects that i
was developing one of which being a
documentary on dementia prevention which
i'm still actually still actually
working on
and that ultimately led to a number of
really incredible opportunities where
i've become collaborators with some of
these researchers i've been able to
publish
literature peer-reviewed academic
literature so i'm um
i'm an author i've written books for the
lay public genius foods and the genius
life but i've also been able to
co-author a chapter in a textbook that
clinicians use wow too yeah it's been
it's been really quite incredible i've
been able to lecture at the new york
academy of sciences and so i may i'm not
i don't i never misrepresent myself i'm
not a medical doctor i'm just incredibly
passionate about something that's become
very personal to me
um and i think i have uh
you know a bit of an aptitude for this
for for understanding and for
um communicating science and i always
remain sort of open to challenging my
own assumptions and beliefs about health
and nutrition and
and the like so
it's again led to a number of incredible
opportunities but really my passion is
helping
people of all ages but particularly
younger people live and eat in a way
that optimizes their brain health and
helps them minimize risk for the kinds
of chronic
non-communicable diseases that we know
are just
ravaging
um society these days and
and making people sick and shortening
people's lifespans
and uh part of that has to do with myth
busting and
um
helping people separate fact from
fiction but
i uh i host a podcast called the genius
life and yeah my two books are out
genius foods and the genius life and
that's actually how we connected i
remember hearing about your story and i
sent you
my first book genius phone
cs yeah and it was um
i was like this could have helped me
years ago
but by that time i was already on the
carnivore train or it might have been
yeah i was i was like just just newly on
the carnivore train you are the guy that
i direct people to if they're like you
know i'm pretty healthy
but i don't want to get chronically ill
later
are there things i could do now i'm like
you should read
genius foods
because that would convince
anybody that
simple changes that really aren't that
hard to implement can
really reduce pain and suffering later
and i think young people
young people who are healthy or who
haven't experienced a family member's
ill health or their own ill health
totally disregard their diet they're
like ah whatever i can eat anything
doesn't matter i'll deal with me being
sick later and it's like you don't know
what being chronically ill is like you
don't want to deal with that you want to
spend a good portion of your time making
sure you do not have to deal with that
because it's horrible
yeah trying to change chronic illness um
feels like trying to
move a cruise ship
with your hands
trying to change the direction of a
cruise ship by pushing it with your
hands that's what it that's what it
feels like because
by the time you've already shown
symptoms the disease has set in like its
claws are already
well embedded and i saw this with my
mother i mean
my mom has a had a form of dementia that
uh is
tragically understudied but that's
because it's rare of course
but if you take alzheimer's disease
which is the most common form of
dementia that begins in the brain 30 to
40 years before the first symptom
this is fact and
parkinson's disease which had
overlapping features with my mom with my
mom's condition
that's another one of these conditions
where by the time you show up to the
neurologist with your first symptom
half of the dopaminergic neurons in the
substantia [ __ ] portion of the brain
where neurons involved in movement
um die in parkinson's disease half of
them are already dead by the time you
show up with your first symptom
and that shouldn't be that
hard to that shouldn't be that shocking
to consider
because the same it's the same story for
cardiovascular you know chronic
cardiovascular disease for
cancer for type 2 diabetes i mean these
conditions take
years to manifest
and so
to me rather than live in fear i think
that's an incredibly empowering
side of the story that we have agency we
have say when it comes to our our health
destiny um
and
unfortunately you know like when i when
i started going to those neurologists
office with my mom
[Music]
thankfully i had the insight that now
for the first time because i had no
prior family history of any kind of
neurodegenerative disease like i thought
alzheimer's disease and parkinson's
disease were something that only really
old people got my mom was not old at the
time
so thankfully i had the insight to
realize that
now for the first time i had a i
actually had a risk factor
for both of these i could develop
exactly what it is that my mom developed
because my mom has that condition
um
and so
it became clear to me that this is
something that younger people needed to
be talking about and so i kind of took
it upon myself to get the message out
there knowing that i wasn't a medical
doctor but that
um
that i had the ability and the and the
desire to communicate science in a way
that was
um balanced and responsible and could
ultimately
make a difference for people
i don't know why some people
i
my audience already knows that i'm
extremely biased and
if somebody is a medical doctor i assume
that they've been taught something wrong
for a really long time so they're going
to be even harder to convince
about whatever you're trying to talk to
them about but
for nutrition and actually being able to
read
literature
that's not even necessarily something
you'd go to a doctor for because they
don't do nutrition specifically
no so
yeah they get i mean they get an
afternoon of nutrition training they get
very little training when it comes to
exercise
um and the power that exercise exercise
is medicine right but they're they're
not taught that
um
and at the end of the day i think it's
important for people to realize that um
there there are some incredible doctors
out there so i can't i can't deny that
but there also are some really bad
doctors there are a lot of really bad
doctors doctors are human for one and
also medical doctors at least in this
country are
they're not scientists they're
technicians you know they're like
trained to
operate according to script and if they
veer from that script
then they run the risk of a malpractice
suit so what doctor is going to
um
you know veer too far from the orthodox
path
with their patient it's just not it's
not really going to happen so you kind
of have to take
matters into your home into your own
hands to some degree
and that's not to say that
me and my mother didn't go to doctors
looking for answers we did i mean i i'm
i
we we wished you know often that there
would be i wish that there would be a
viable that there would actually be a
viable
pharmaceutical
agent that could that could provide
relief for my mom and there and there
wasn't
my mother actually she passed
uh
a little over two years ago and she so
she had struggled from dementia for
seven eight years but
she was diagnosed with pancreatic cancer
labor day 2018
and
so it was just i mean it was it was
awful but what i experienced with her
with oncologists was the same thing that
i had experienced with her with a
neurologist it was like complete deja vu
they were just they weren't able to
offer her anything i'm not faulting
um
mainstream medicine for that you know we
certainly
went there as opposed to some of these
more alternative
you know options
which
you know
there's no evidence for you know for
these alternatives you know treatments
but um
uh but yeah it's just like
to me i think prevention is so crucially
important and we don't know everything
at this point but i think we know enough
where we don't have to sit idly on our
hands
i agree so before we delve into some of
the things people can easily implement
that could potentially save them from
years of suffering
down the road um
how did you
i wanted to ask you because i've had
my own share of family health
troubles
how did you manage to stay
sane
during the stress of dealing with
somebody chronically ill oh man such a
good question i love that you asked this
question because
you know especially when you have
somebody who is on a loved one who's on
hospice um
you want to spend every moment with that
person but
for me i knew that if i didn't carve out
time in my day every day for self-care
that i wouldn't have made it to the
other side
and so that's where to me exercise was
my savior um
during especially during those those
final three months of my mom's life
i
made an effort to get to the gym every
single day and my life
at that point had been incredibly
stressful i mean there was like
obviously what my mother was going
through but there was infighting in my
family you know about her treatment and
it was just like
it was so stressful but i every day i
went to the gym and then i took time out
and i was sauna
you know i was like hitting the sauna
almost every day cold plunge almost
every day i mean there's such a bounty
of evidence now showing us that exercise
is a tonic for mental health and so and
i experienced that firsthand you know
whether it was anxiety or depression
which is something that we all
experience right there's such a robust
but there is meta-analyses now coming
out that are showing us that whether
it's cardio whether it's more aerobic
style training or resistance training
both are super effective in treating
even clinical cases of of severe
depression
um
and anxiety so
that i mean that was a major outlet for
me just getting to the gym i mean it
feels so good
you know you get that endorphin rush
it helps balance neurotransmitters
hormones
um you're boosting bdnf in the brain so
you're keeping your brain plastic
and agile all the while
just there's so many so many mechanisms
by which exercise fortifies
your mental health so that was a big
that was a big one for me eating healthy
i think is a is a huge part of it as
well we know now thanks to this growing
field that's being called nutritional
psychiatry that food has a powerful say
in terms of mood my diet was already
quite good um you know pretty privileged
in the sense that you know i had this
foundation of nutritional knowledge so
unlike most americans whose diets are 60
ultra processed foods mine tend to be
more whole foods and so
um we know
that when people
with severe depression make the switch
from an ultra processed foods diet to a
diet that's more whole foods more
mediterranean style that
uh that seems to help um with mood you
know so for me that was just like a
foundational thing i don't know of
changing my if if my diet my diet was
certainly supporting um
everything that i was doing in the gym
and the like but
it's self-care it's really self-care
it's you've got to make time for it for
any caregivers listening anybody who's
doing anything stressful i mean
don't start to judge yourself or your
situation until you've had a workout and
then reassess the other day i woke up
and you know i still have bouts where i
wake up sad about what transpired and i
was i felt gloomy i had no motivation to
even get to the gym but i forced myself
to go to the gym
and everything cleared up and
it felt amazing so
um so yeah exercise really when it comes
to mental health and and weathering the
storm so to speak exercises it's
profound
this episode is sponsored by carnivore
crisps
because it's about health and i love
them and carnivore crisps rock
if you're on instagram you've definitely
seen me post about them i can't get
enough of their beef
rib eye brisket so good carnivore crisps
give you an all-natural and delicious
alternative to snacking this isn't even
snacking you could survive off of these
i do
dad basically does
most so-called health snacks come loaded
with preservatives and artificial
ingredients that's not a problem with
carnivore crisps they're only made with
beef and salt or chicken and salt
or pork and salt
they're like tostitos and levels of
tastiness you can snack the way nature
intended with the only snack that truly
helps you reach your peak performance
meat
add some crisps to your regiment and
experience the difference made with real
meat and real salt real salt
if you guys know real salt they're cool
too carnivore diet approved lion diet
approved michaela approved do yourself a
favor
give yourself a better and healthier
snack
this is what they look like they're like
really thin like tostitos
i'm crunchy like tostitos
so crunchy
cottenbergcrisps.com code mp
for 10 off
carnivorecrisps.comcodemp i should also
mention real quick
they make
little dog treats that are also just
meat and salt and water
because dogs should need other things
that are also really good look how cute
they are beef burgers okay back to the
episode
i need to be more disciplined with that
i've got like there's some stressful
seriously stressful things going on and
it's like when you first get hit with
that load of stress
i'm just like ta first i'm full of
adrenaline right for like
an extended period of time but when that
wears off i'm just tired
and i'm like and then i know that
exercise would help
but i'm so tired
but the cold plunge is pretty easily
implementable it's like
pretty lazy
and still managed to do a cold plunge
yeah it's painful i think any time you
get out of your comfort zone
um
good things happen and getting into a
cold plunge it's rarely
easy to do i mean it's it's difficult to
do but
the benefits are profound i mean there
there's a researcher charles rezan i
believe he's studying
uh cold exposure and mood there have
been a number of case reports published
on pubmed
where winter swimming you know seems to
offer reprieve from even the most severe
depression so i'm not saying to
circumvent pharmaceuticals if that's
what you need you know i would never
place a stigma on on pharmaceutical
intervention but like
but i think you should always they
[ __ ] me up guys i placed the stigma
there
i wouldn't be up for years
yeah anyway
yeah i'm not i'm not endorsing them but
i'm saying but but you know
meta-analyses tend to show that
well we know that
antidepressant drugs are very much
overprescribed and that for people with
mild to moderate depression
they're
no more effective than placebo and
exercise is just as effective if not
more so
um but they are they are effective for
people with severe depression
it seems to seems to be the case and so
until they try and get off of them oh
yeah well my mom was on [ __ ] luck
there
my my mom had been on search really for
many many years
and
we tried to get which is zoloft and we
tried to
get her off of that and we realized what
a nightmare that is to come off of
yeah
um yeah i don't think i would have made
it off mine so i was on ciprolex uh and
so that's an ssri and i was at a pretty
high dose through like developmental
years and when my depression went away
when i went low carb like it went away
while i was on them
and i was like ah well don't need this
anymore and kind of stop taking them
over a period of two weeks because i
literally didn't know that you could
have antidepressant withdrawal and the
reason i ended up on the zero carb diet
now looking back i know this i didn't at
the time the reason i ended up on it was
because my brain was in such a state of
constant panic from stopping those
antidepressants that i was getting ssri
withdrawal from
tiny little amounts of carbs so like
light heat sound
and then carbs it's gone now i don't
have antidepressants any uh withdrawal
anymore and so i don't get those mood
dips when i have carbs anymore thank god
but
i'm not very happy with that experience
especially considering i didn't know
what was going on for like two and a
half years
yeah i just think that diet and
lifestyle should always be the first
line of defense so like yeah
work with that and
see where you are then see yeah see
where you are exactly yeah okay so for
things people could change if you're
your average joe you're on a standard
american diet you're getting a slump in
the afternoon
maybe you're a little have some covert
weight like what are some easy things
people could change to improve their
lives
well i think i mean one of the things
that i've done recently or that i do
regularly that i think really helps me
is i take uh hiatuses from caffeine
um are you a coffee drinker
no i i couldn't drink coffee either i
can drink tea now
so i'm pretty proud of that i just
discovered milk long have you had milk
oolong tea oh i heard you post i saw you
post about that and i googled it
it's amazing it doesn't have any milk
it's like fermented
oolong tea and it tastes like milk and i
haven't had milk since 2015 and it is
so good i can't picture like a tea that
tastes like milk i'm gonna have to pick
up so good i think if you
have had milk maybe it doesn't taste as
much like milk as i think it tastes like
milk but anyway milk oolong it's great
people should try it anyway caffeine
well i know that this is going to be a
polar yeah the the caffeine abstention
is going to be you know is going to
make some people hate me but um but i
love coffee and i love caffeine but i i
find that it definitely messes me up and
it's you know i was in denial for a long
time about it but um
you know i drink it i drink it typically
first thing in the morning and i always
you know i either if i if i've if i
consume too much i experience that wired
and tired sort of burnout feeling or i
just i feel like i've been hit by a
train later in the afternoon
um and so
i've you know at this point now i've
taken i've done this a number of times
where i'll take a
one to two to three or month long hiatus
from
uh
from caffeine and i feel like i feel
incredible like when i when i do it it's
it makes me almost not want to go back
to drinking caffeine but i do happen to
love the taste of coffee
um
but whenever i take these breaks from
from caffeine i think it's you know
because here's what happens when you
become dependent on caffeine
caffeine is an ergogenic compound so
it's a performance booster it boosts
mental acuity it boosts physical
performance in the gym we know that when
you have an acute dose of caffeine
however i think when people are
dependent on it the boost that they're
getting isn't a boost from their
baseline performance it's merely
treating their withdrawal from caffeine
and so you you need to continue to dose
yourself with caffeine to have
even your baseline level of of
performance
whereas
you know when i i find that when i take
time off of it
i go back to having baseline
my baseline level of performance as my
actual baseline and then whenever i
bring caffeine back in at the minimal
effective dose i'm actually able to
have superior performance to to my to my
baseline so i think the key is to just
not become dependent on it and to cycle
it to cycle caffeine which you know
people do with other supplements in the
fitness space but um
so i think i think that's a big that's a
big thing for me at least currently so
currently i'm i'm off caffeine i'm
sipping some lines i mean
uh in a cup
um
but yeah
and then i mean we could talk about diet
we could talk about lifestyle i'm really
you know
i think you and i share
an affinity for
animal-sourced animal-based products
um you know i'm a i'm big on on
on
quality meat um fish eggs things like
that
really supportive uh in my view of brain
health i mean the the strongest body of
evidence supports fish you know i mean
you can't you can't deny that fish
is medicine when it comes to the brain
but i think that red meat um is as well
and uh and eggs you know eggs
wonderful source of choline which is the
precursor to acetylcholine which is an
important neurotransmitter
for learning and memory um about 10
percent of the population consumes the
adequate intake for choline
which is shocking
um
and there also happens to be a risk
reduction for people for the highest
tier of choline consumers i believe it's
about a 30 risk reduction for dementia
so observational correlation but um
but i think choline is a pretty pretty
important nutrient among many that you
find in animal foods
okay yeah so
we we talked i think last time we talked
a little bit
about diet and i do want to touch on
that but for genius life
can you tell me
some of the things that
are important in that book
yeah and i want to cover makeup too oh
no you saw some post about well i wear
makeup and i'm like [ __ ] it i don't get
autoimmune symptoms from makeup and
anything that doesn't give me autoimmune
symptoms from i'm like i'll do it but
i've heard you talk about a whole bunch
of poisonous chemicals in makeup
yeah
um
i don't know if i'll be able to list
them at this point uh but they're but
but basically the point that i was
trying to drive home in the genius life
and with cosmetics and bathroom products
and the like
is that we're exposed to any number of
industrial chemicals on a daily basis
and we don't yet have the kind of
long-term data to know whether or not
these come these compounds are safe
every once in a while there will be a
big lawsuit like what happened recently
with johnson and johnson and
their talc powder which was contaminated
which had been contaminated with
asbestos
oh my god i didn't know about this was
it asbestos or arsenic it was like it
was it was one of these you know don't
don't don't quote me on that be terrible
it's pretty bad too yeah it was it was
one it was basically one of those it's
very easily googleable but women you
know and and men people boys
uh
put this stuff on their genitals and
women were developing
rare
vaginal cancers
um
you know at it at dramatically increased
risk when they had been using this
product chronically
cancer did you google it yeah it's
asbestos holy [ __ ] wasn't that isn't
that for babies oh my god i didn't know
this it's that's it's it's terrifying so
you know i like to abide by the
precautionary principle um which
stipulates that the less time a product
or a supplement or a medicine or an
industrial compound has been you know
in the sort of human
um
like in our sort of ecosystem
the greater burden of proof it should
bear before we deem it as safe and
oftentimes that burden is placed on
consumers really it's not placed on on
manufacturers and so
a lot of these compounds
well for one they exhibit endocrine
disrupting potential
and there's this big debate
so your endocrine system is your is your
they're your hormones you know you have
leptin ghrelin insulin growth hormone
your sex hormones like estrogen
testosterone
primarily these endocrine disrupting
compounds
are thought to disrupt
sex hormones and thyroid hormone
and
the problem is that
toxins typically when we think about
toxins
follow a linear
um
the the greater the dose the greater the
risk of toxicity the greater the danger
posed by any any chemical really the
dose makes the poison
that
what we call that is a monotonic dose
response it's like a linear dose
response increasing dose increasing dose
increasing toxicity the problem with
endocrine disrupting chemicals is that
they follow what's called a
non-monotonic dose response so it's more
like a u-shaped curve they can have one
effect at a at a high dose
but they can have a completely different
effect at a very low dose
and we don't
know how to study all of the different
chemicals that are suspected to have
this
to have this ability to disrupt our
hormones
so what that means is that you know they
might test
one of these compounds at a certain dose
and and and find the dose at which point
it becomes toxic and then below that
they say oh well it's safe
but at the point is that at a low dose
they can have a completely different and
still
harmful effect the endocrine disruption
exchange which was a non-profit doing
great work and i think they've
they've shuddered but
they've identified about 1 400 compounds
that humans are exposed to routinely
that have the potential for endocrine
disruption and endocrine disruption is
like
i mean the the potential consequences of
disrupting your hormones can be anything
from
you know unwarranted fat gain to low
libido to
improper
cognitive development and improper brain
development thyroid hormone for example
is important for the development of our
of of our brains as we're growing up
um
and so
that's where i think it's important to
be really weary of uh you know
industrial compounds and that's not to
say that natural products aren't
necessarily safer but i think that
um
but you know i just i don't i don't
necessarily trust
compounds as readily when they're
synthetic and we're told to just slather
them on also many of these products like
cosmetics
um which you brought up you know they're
not
we don't like we don't ingest them so
they're not tested
for that
but they still are able to enter
circulation whether it's through hand to
mouth behavior you know we touch our
face and then we touch our mouths
they get they're able to get into our
skin
uh we know that bpa for example is able
to to get into our skin and enter
circulation
um even certain types of dental floss
like dental tape for example
dental tape is made of
substances
substances that are used to make teflon
or non-stick pans
and
yeah and we know
yeah definitely not ideal these are
powerful endocrine endocrine disruptors
there's a whole movie with mark ruffalo
called dark waters all about this how
you know these compounds are
carcinogenic
um
yeah they're called perfluorinated
alkylated substances or pfas for short
and dental tape
is made using those kinds of substances
and so you want to avoid those and use
dental floss instead but yeah there's
there's so many and i think it's it's
not worth
you know going crazy over because you're
not going to be able to completely
eliminate your exposure to these kinds
of things but
you know
in in my view i think it's just
important to become aware of um
these kinds of things and
uh
yeah and then from that point you know
with that information
i think what it tends to do is it tends
to lead to either not necessarily using
these products you know for example like
fragrance products we're told okay
thanks to thanks to marketing right that
like humans
like should smell a certain way
you know
and that all bad odors are like you know
something that we want to like
put a put a
chemical band-aid over
um
but
fragrances are among the most notorious
they're made using phthalates the term
fragrance on a you know on a on a
cosmetic label
could be an umbrella
which
you know which hides hundreds of
chemicals under its under that under
that singular term so
um so yeah i think i think
the the best course of action is just to
sort of minimize our exposure to these
and to and to opt for natural food-based
sources that you know i mean something
that you might that you might consume
would be something that i would
uh
you know use on my like
face or to brush my teeth with or
um to wash myself with
lanolin is really good if you need a lip
gloss it also works as a moisturizer
lanolin is great
uh i use half tallow i have like a beef
from belcampo i have like a beef towel
oh do they have lip balm yeah okay i've
i've tried one of those i prefer lanolin
just because i just find it just it's
extremely effective like i used to use
before i got all health conscious i used
to use vaseline when i switched over to
lanolin but um i was traveling speaking
of fragrances i was traveling this
summer and i went i was in croatia and i
got into this house and i've gotten
i guess
i've have things set up so well in my
own home that i forget how many things
can go wrong when you travel but i got
in there and there was this hor
something scented and it was so strong
that i was like this is nauseating like
i don't know how someone can be in here
so i had to search around they had this
weird
container full of this oil with these
sticks coming out of it and they were
just everywhere so i put them all in the
laundry close the laundry but then it
was like
the sheets were covered in
whatever soap they were using was
scented so the sheets had this like
film of scented soap on them and i was
like does anyone does anyone like this
like there's so many things like now i'm
not gonna be able to sleep i have to
sleep with a towel on my pillow because
my head is gonna smell like this stupid
pillow i was like how do people survive
well like using scented laundry
detergent
how do you live like that
yeah i mean i buy everything that i buy
in my house is like it's you know
scented with like essential oils and
things like that and i know it sounds
really woo and i know that there are
going to be people in the audience who
are like oh nature fallacy you know like
natural doesn't necessarily mean
mean that it's safe but
um
but there are just too many examples
throughout history where
industry has foisted a
compound on to the public
you know only later to have seen
the unintended consequences unfurl so
you know as about we talked to asbestos
and talc asbestos in our
in our building you know materials lead
in paint for example you know lead and
paint they thought oh it helps speed up
the drying of paint
what they didn't account for was the
fact that paint over time
sloughs off becomes dust particles in
our in our homes we breathe it in we
touch it it ends up in our
you know in our
circulating systemically the same thing
with bpa you know bisphenol a is a is a
well-known
endocrine disruptor it's been known for
100 years at this point that it's a
xenoestrogen it's like a synthetic form
of estrogen and our many of our plastic
products are made of it
but it's not inert you know it's able to
migrate out in the form of dust
leech out into our food when we you know
use
bpa
containers that are made using bpa and
we store
fatty acidic salty foods in it
it comes off on our cash registers
cash register receipts and that ends up
in our mouths you know due to
the hand to mouth behavior
um and also through the skin so
there's there are all these just there
are too many examples throughout history
and um
when i look at like my mom's life
she wasn't she wasn't skeptical at all i
mean she just kind of she was very
health conscious but she
listened to the messages that were that
were sent to her via marketing the you
know traditional marketing channels
um
and so
her home she used all the cosmetics and
her home was cleaned using just the
standard cleaning products that were
fragranced
um up the wazoo and so
i i just think it's important to be you
know a little bit more a little bit more
skeptical and to have your own sort of
you know to have your own back when it
comes to
minimizing exposure to these kinds of
compounds because because corporations
don't we know that
yeah i would say be extremely skeptical
i'm so skeptical it's unbelievable but i
don't seem to be
i haven't been wrong
about a lot of the things i'm skeptical
about
and people
a lot of people who tell you they know
what they're talking about too
or like oh this is fine they don't know
what they're talking about
and you you touched on this earlier
you're like the newer the chemical or
the newer the drug
it doesn't mean better i i had um a
couple of people on to talk about
pharmaceuticals specifically psychiatric
medications and it was like they'll come
out with a new one and they'll say this
is the best one that one has the least
amount of data
right yeah so
yeah yeah well
a wonderful and topical example is the
recent alzheimer's drug adjecanimab
released by
biogen and fast tracked for approval
from the fda right
that drug it was there hasn't been a new
alzheimer's drug to hit the market in 15
years
and alzheimer's drug trials have a a
notoriously abysmal success rate
um their failure rate is 99.6 percent so
99.6 percent of alzheimer's drug trials
fail
but this adjective drug
was fast-tracked
and obviously a lot of people are very
hopeful because there are very few
effective pharmaceutical treatment
modalities for alzheimer's disease
but
it's been controversial because the drug
has been shown to reduce levels of
amyloid beta in the brain which is the
plaque most closely associated with
alzheimer's disease you know alzheimer's
disease is characterized in part by this
aggregation of amyloid the the
amyloid beta plaque
as well as
misfolded tau protein in the brain
and the drug has been shown to be
successful in reducing plaque burden in
the brain but it hasn't been shown to
move the needle on the most obvious and
clinically relevant endpoint which is
cognitive function so it the drug hasn't
been shown to actually help the
cognition or extend life
in people with alzheimer's disease
it just reduces this you know this
plaque in the brain
um which who's to say that that is even
causal when it comes to alzheimer's
disease i mean
the amyloid hypothesis is still a
hypothesis and so
yeah i'm uh
i think you just have to be a skeptic
you know no don't be don't it's
important not to be cynical about these
kinds of things but i think um
skepticism is something that we don't
have enough of and i think that
falls in line with our just overall lack
of scientific literacy in this country
um you know we all need to learn i think
more about how to think like a scientist
you know i'm i'm
not
formally trained but
uh but my experience with my mom my
passion to help others my
my curiosity and my desire for
for knowledge has has led me down a path
where
you know i mean being being skeptical is
crucially important i'm constantly even
questioning my own beliefs about
um
and assertions that i've made about
about diet and lifestyle and the like
agreed yeah so important
it is important
how important is it to eat organic food
does it really matter
oh man
um i eat organic when i'm eating the
skin or the rind or the whole fruit or
vegetable um i don't think it's
important to buy organic
uh when it comes to something that you
know has a as a rind or a peel like i
would never buy an organic banana or
avocado
um i think it's important that people
know that there's very little
nutritional difference when it comes to
when comparing organic versus
conventional
and
you know
ultimately
if you know if you want to eat fruits
and vegetables and conventional is the
is the only form that is available to
you whether
you know because of access or because of
you know finances um
i think conventional is fine there's
very little when it comes to like
there's very little difference when it
comes to like essential nutrients but
um
organic
does have
uh
very low um
very low risk of ingesting synthetic
pesticides when consuming organic they
do use herbicides and pesticides in
organic but they're organic approved and
some of them include
you know copper for example which is an
essential mineral
vitamin d is an example of another
organic approved
pesticide so
you know anti sort of organic zealots
will say well you know organic still
contain pesticides but you're not
getting the synthetic pesticides is i
think the point
also there's lower risk of
exposure to certain heavy metals like
cadmium
in organic produce and you're also
getting higher levels of plant defense
compounds
like polyphenols which are going to be
higher in organic produce
because these are compounds that plants
naturally will generate to ward off uh
predation
um and so you're getting more in organic
you're getting less in in conventionally
raised produce it's
you know it's kind of splitting hairs i
think um for somebody on a on a limited
budget you know i think that there's a
lot of
people in the wellness world
project this image of perfection that if
you can't eat organic all the time then
somehow you're not you know you've
you're a moral failure i don't think
that that's necessarily the case but i
you know i definitely
try to eat organic when uh when it comes
to dark leafy greens when it comes to
berries
um things like that
another completely anecdotal data point
um you know my mother is somebody who
never believed in organic she just
didn't believe in it
um
you know whether it was
her trying to save money or whatever you
know she
ate conventionally grown produce her her
whole life so
um again
not saying to draw any conclusions from
that but um
but you know i'm i'm sort of in a place
where i want to
examine every aspect of her life and and
kind of go in the opposite direction
because her health was so tragic so
uh
so yeah i you know those are my those
are my feelings on on organic
how important is it to eat
unprocessed foods
i think that's crucially important i
mean i you know we love to argue in this
space about
animal
based versus plant-based low-carb versus
low-fat
i think the key determinant of
successful aging
um is really going to be
the degree of processing
uh that you're that the bulk of the
foods that you consume undergo if you're
your standard
sort of amer your average american
consuming 60 ultra processed foods what
does that mean ultra processed does that
look like
yeah so i mean if you there's like a
spectrum of processing that a food can
undergo so if you look at like a piece
of steak that's meat that has been
processed right you've cooked it you've
you've basically outsourced some degree
of digestion to make the steak
more palatable
easier to break down same goes for
vegetables when you cook vegetables
we're processing when we're when we're
cutting things you know with a knife and
fork we're processing them to some
degree ultra processing is when you know
for example you take grain flour and you
just you know put it through these
myriad processes that make
it
so easily digestible that it even though
it's not
overt sugar it's not uh sugar
necessarily it basically is no different
to your body it becomes so rapidly
broken down and absorbed at the top of
your small intestine
um same you know
ultra processing also occurs to fats so
like grain and seed oils like canola oil
corn oil soybean oil i'm very skeptical
of those i don't i try to you know avoid
consuming any of those oils because the
processing damages those fats that are
very delicate because of their high
their preponderance of polyunsaturated
fatty acids and
we know that one step in the production
process deodorization actually creates a
small but significant amount of trans
fats in those in those oils
and we know that there's no safe
level of
of trans fat consumption at this point
um
so it's like it's all those pro package
processed foods that you see
you know lining your supermarket shelves
like
in the in through the aisles which is
where the ultra-processed foods tend to
tend to be they're the chips they're the
commercial cereals commercial breads
pizzas pastas they're um
you know they're just they're made
with machinery and so it's it basically
outsources a degree of
uh
you know it takes very little effort for
your body to assimilate
um there's probably a relationship
between the degree of processing and the
speed at which we were able to consume
these foods so i think that speed in and
of itself is um
potentially one of the problems with the
food like
they're very easy to chew
ultra processed foods you know they
don't require any sort of
jaw vigor to uh to to chew and break
down
you know our bodies begin to assimilate
them almost immediately that flood of
sugar you know if we're talking about
refined grain products hit the
bloodstream super rapidly leads to a
huge flood of of insulin and
um
yeah there's a i did an interview with
um former fda commissioner david kessler
who thinks that
you know he basically echoed this that
ultra processing is like one of the
you know biggest problems with the
modern food supply also
you know you absorb 100
of the calories of an ultra processed
food whereas a minimally processed food
like you know say you're consuming a
handful of nuts
or um you know some like
uh you know barely ripe vegetable or or
uh or fruit or you know even meat
products like
you know
you're losing a percentage
of these calories nuts for example about
30 of the calories of whole nuts just
pass through you
you know because you're chewing them
yourself but you're you're you're not
necessarily able to break them down as
fully as
you know if you were to be consuming
nuts in the form of nut butter which is
like
you know a very processed form of nuts
so i think that there are all these sort
of issues when it comes to ultra
processing also nutrient depletion i
mean that's another whole other thing
when you look at
the packaged processed foods in our in
our
supermarkets so often they're fortified
with synthetic vitamins and minerals
because the processing of these foods
depletes them of nutrition that's one of
the reasons why 90 of americans are
deficient in at least one essential
nutrient so
i would say that
yeah i mean when looking at the world's
blue zones they're
you know
people like walter longo david sinclair
they love to
yeah
they love to make questions cherry-pick
the fact that they eat sort of you know
lower protein
diets but there's all there are all
these variables that are different but
when it comes to diet i would say the
key
the the the biggest difference is that
they're eating diet they're eating foods
that are minimally processed save for
the processing that they do themselves
when they cook their food
one of my questions was
what about this
link between red meat consumption and
not living very long
yeah so i i'm a huge fan of red meat i
do definitely um
you know i i try to sort of
i situate i'm i think i'm situated sort
of in the middle where i see the value
of red of red meat and i eat it all the
time but i also
think that there is merit to the notion
that
excessively fatty meat should be
moderated and my reasoning for that is
that
you know if you look at wild game while
game is all they're it's incredibly lean
if you take a cow and you compare
especially a grain finished cow when you
compare
you know its constituent fat to the fat
of wild game it's way way fattier
i think grass-finished
beef is is
way healthier in part because we know
that it's actually leaner i mean grass a
cow that's eating its biologically
appropriate diet is going to be is going
to be leaner and some people have genes
that cause them to have an over response
when it comes to their
you know their lipid profile to diets
that are excessively high in in
saturated fat so
while i'm a huge fan of red meat i
personally you know and i and i do eat
fat you know fatty meat all the time i
love a good rib eye i love
you know barbecue ribs and stuff like
that but i do try
um for the most part to reach for
leaner um
cuts of red meat now do i think that
there's
like when when all that is said and done
there's anything inherently unhealthy
about red meat now i think it's actually
quite healthy i think it's a superfood
in fact i call it a genius food um it's
packed with
nutrients that we know are important for
the brain and body nutrients of concern
so i mean like we talked about choline
earlier and how ten percent of the
population consume the adequate intake
for choline
beef is you know an amazing source a
great source of vitamin b12 it's a great
source of iron it's a great source of
zinc
um you get tiny amounts of omega-3s but
i think that that's worth something
you also get creatine which you know i
would call creatine a conditionally
essential nutrient because we know that
people who are
on diets that lack
exogenous creatine when and when
supplemented they see an improvement in
their cognitive function
so
yeah beef i think is a superfood when it
comes to the brain but
you know we also have to be cognizant of
the fact that
um
the brain is fed blood and you know
which contain nutrients and oxygen by a
network of micro vessels that are
incredibly delicate and tiny and that if
you were to take out of your head and
stack end to end would stretch 400 miles
long and that vascular vasculature needs
to be protected and so that's where sort
of cardiovascular health and the science
on
you know
lipids and stuff is very fascinating to
me
and i think also quite important
and
and so yeah so for example like there's
some some thinking and evidence that
people that are genetically at risk for
alzheimer's disease carriers of the
apoe4 allele for example
have a sort of an exaggerated response
when it comes to their ldl cholesterol
when they consume
excess saturated fat what saturated fat
does is it reduces the amount of ldl
receptors on the on the surface of the
liver so what that can do is it can
cause ldl basically
you know these lipoproteins that
circulate cholesterol and triglycerides
through your blood to to build up in the
blood and i don't think that's
uh
a positive scenario and so
um so yeah so i think it's it's
ultimately about balance do i think that
pro that do i think that there's
anything
potentially harmful about
high protein diets no i think that
protein is crucially important um
especially as you get older there's
evidence that people over 65
live longer and have lower risk of
cancer when they consume more protein we
know that people
um in their elder years experience
anabolic resistance protein resistance
so i think protein is incredibly
important and meat animal products are
pristine sources of protein you know
among them the highest quality that we
have access to so
uh
so yeah so i'm a huge huge fan
of of
red meat
how do you feel about people who say
it doesn't matter what you eat it just
matters how much and you should just be
looking at calories
yeah i love this question um
well
i disagree 100
um
because i think
you know
we all know that you can eat a diet of
twinkies and as long as you're in a
calorie deficit you'll lose weight right
but what kind of weight are you going to
be losing you know so so right off the
bat we know
that we want to optimize for protein so
as not to
so as to minimize muscle protein
breakdown right so that's so that's one
stipulation
we also know that the body has a
requirement for certain micronutrients
and we know that many of these nutrients
especially nutrients that are supportive
of optimal brain and mental health are
nutrients of concern
and so you can't just eat anything and
expect to
you can perhaps eat anything and lose
weight but are you losing the right
weight and are you going to feel good
and be healthy in the process and so
i'm not one of these like obsessive
fitness guys who thinks that it's all
about you know what the scale says or
how you look in the mirror to me it's
about
living a long time
healthily you know optimizing for life
span optimizing for a health span and
looking good and being strong in the
process which are completely related to
uh living long and healthfully right
like feeling good feeling strong
vigorous robust
and so and so yeah so i disagree with
that statement
i do agree though that that for somebody
who is very overweight you know
ultimately finding the diet that's going
to be most sustainable for them is
really the key determining factor and
you can lose weight
and shift and and
you know recompose your body
with
a number of different diets low-fat diet
low-carb diet full-on ketogenic diet
you can do it with a vegan diet
ultimately i think the key determinant
of success is what is
what you're going to actually be able to
sustain
and so that's where i think i'm a little
bit less dogmatic but
i think where i
am a stickler is i'm big on food quality
and i think that
it's going to make it a lot easier for
you to embrace a diet that is minimally
processed
we have data now from the nih there was
that 2018 kevin hall study that found
that people
on ultra processed diets
when
when invited to consume ultra-processed
foods add libitum meaning to satiety
all the food that they wanted they ended
up eating a 500 calorie per day
surplus
and if you stretch that out over the
course of the week 500 calories a day
that's a pound of fat gain every week
when they took those same people and
they gave them minimally processed foods
to consume
they ended up coming in at a calorie
deficit by about 300 calories so that's
an 800 calorie swing right there
determined purely by what you're eating
not by how much you're eating so what
it's what seems to be the case is that
what you eat determines
at least to some degree to a significant
degree how much you're eating and so if
we focus on food quality
which obviously implies that we're going
to be getting you know more nutrients
from those foods as well higher quality
nutrients as well
um
that basically will do the work for you
and i think because diet you know
sustaining
a weight loss diet is so difficult for
so many people i think that's really the
that's the elephant in the room that a
lot of these like seco calories and
calories out
zealots aren't talking about calories
and calories out isn't a weight loss
strategy it's a mathematical truth but
people promote it almost as if it's a
you know like as if it should be a
weight loss strategy
and it's not i think it's a major
disservice to
the public to
to
put the focus on calories and not
the behavioral effects of the foods that
they're eating
so basically if you're eating
unprocessed foods or
less processed foods
you're less likely to overeat
absolutely yeah that's what that that
kevin hall studies easier yeah yeah so
you don't have to count the calories you
can just eat until you're full and
you're full faster with less processed
foods i don't i mean looks calorie
counting works for some people right i
mean there are obsessive people in the
fitness space there are people who have
never in their life audited what it is
that they're eating and so i think you
know there is a there is utility to to
calorie count but i think when it comes
to again sustainability um do you want
to be tethered to your food scale i
don't think so and you know me many of
my followers at this point you know
like
the the the
sort of anecdotal data that i've seen
from just from my following and having
my work been out for now a number of
years you know people are able to
achieve and maintain
great you know body composition almost
effortlessly when just thinking about
the
the quality of their food and then they
get all those other benefits we talked
about nutritional psychiatry we talked
about the some of the nutrients that the
brain needs to thrive you're also like
you're you're checking off all those
boxes at the same time so
that's why yeah
food quality is is crucially important
and you know just going back to that
study your average american
is in an ad-libitum ultra-processed
feeding environment like your
your average american is eating 60 of
their
calories
from ultra processed foods because
they're just they're always around
that's what the
that's just like the
you know that's the double-edged sword
of the industrialization of our
industrialization of our food supply
um
and that's why we see these the obesity
statistics that we're now seeing you
know two-thirds of adults are either
overweight or obese by the year 2050 one
in two adults like half of the
population is going to be obese not just
overweight but obese so
it's it's shocking but i think um
again that's really bad
that's like that's gonna get really bad
if things don't change i feel like some
of the people who are doing this
calories in calories out thing are like
30 or 25
and they've only ever been overweight by
like six pounds and they're like oh well
i calorie count and you know and i keep
fit but it's like have you ever been 250
pounds and then you calorie counted your
way
to a hundred pound weight loss or are
you just telling other people to do that
because you think
sustaining your six pound weight loss
was difficult
yeah also many of them probably
bordering borderline orthorexic you know
and
and even if even if they're not that
they come from the fitness world where
you know many of them are or have been
bodybuilders and i'm not saying again
that calorie counting and tracking
vigorously
has no
uh has no has no place like you know
right now i'm in
i'm in gr you know i'm in
uh i have a body composition that i'm
happy with i'm about 13 14
body fat and i know that if i wanted to
get if i wanted to start to see veins in
my abs i would have to start tracking
you know if i want to get down to that
um
if i wanted to to dial in my diet that
rigorously and and have and if my body
composition goals were
were that extreme
which which are extreme
then yeah of course i would have to
track but
i don't think that one
should have to track to
attain a body composition that is
healthy for them
and
healthy is a you know it's a spectrum
like
you know you don't have to have eight or
nine percent
or 10 body fat to be healthy you can you
know
uh
yeah you have some leeway there and i
don't think that calorie counting
is the answer but it may be for you you
know the listener so
uh and if it works for you keep doing it
yes that is true if you found something
that works keep doing it but if you're
hitting yourself over the head with a
bat trying the same thing and it hasn't
worked for you then maybe start doing
some research and looking around at
other options yeah if you're trying to
moderate your consumption of ultra
processed foods you should know that
those foods are not designed to be
consumed in moderation they're not
consumed they're not designed to be
consumed in moderation and we know
from
you know actual peer-reviewed scientific
research that it's very hard to moderate
our consumption of those foods so
you know for somebody who's just hearing
the
age-old dogma to eat less and move more
if they take what it is that they're
what they're currently eating again 60
ultra-processed foods and then they just
like cut their portions in half that to
me is a recipe for hunger and failure
i agree
yeah okay max
is there anything else we should talk
about i i it's been an hour i asked you
a whole bunch of questions
people are hopefully filled with hope
i yeah well it's always great to see you
and um you know and i'm
you know you look radiant and uh thank
you yeah always great always great to
jam i know we you know we we we
definitely agree more on what we you
know than what we disagree on
um
i agree i do tell people to go over to
your
instagram you have a great instagram
everybody listening max has a great
instagram for like
getting
you do a little bit of
calling people out for not people out
but ideas out for not being true
we've got the same general idea about
processed foods and what it takes to be
healthy so it's an instagram i would
recommend checking out
yeah i try not to call people out i
don't think that it's productive i think
it's it creates a it's a it's a negative
energy and there are a lot of people in
the fitness space that love
it's almost as if their whole careers
are alive it gets clicks
calling people out yeah
it's it gets very clicky there's a lot
of tribalism but for me i try not to pay
attention too much to what anybody else
is doing um i just stay focused on
what i believe to be true based on the
data that i've seen
um
and uh
and yeah and and and really helping
people that's what it's about for me
because you know i didn't get started in
this
to sell books even though i'm very
grateful that my books sell i didn't you
know get started in it to be to have a
successful podcast even though i'm very
grateful that people actually listen to
to my show
um it really started for me
um with uh with a very sick loved one
and my desire to to not see what
happened to her
happen to others that i care about so
um i think people get that that it comes
from
an authentic place and
and i always i'm always listening to
people when people have feedback i love
getting feedback from others and
um and yeah i like to keep the
conversation constructive
cool
where can people find you if they don't
follow you already
uh instagram max lugavir um
take a picture of my book genius foods
uh or the genius life and they can come
over and subscribe to my podcast which
is called the genius life and uh hope to
get you on it soon so we gotta schedule
that we should schedule that yes thank
you very much for coming on that was fun
likewise thanks for having me
[Music]
you